(upbeat music)
- Hey guys, I'm Kelly.
And today, Jasmine has challenged me
to make all of my meals for the day
in a mug in the microwave.
In the restaurant world, we
call this bad boy Chef Mike
and he's definitely not
getting any Michelin stars,
so I'm a little iffy about it.
And at the end, Jasmine is
going to give me a yay or a nay.
Let's see if we can whip
up some gourmet meals
that Jasmine likes.
All right, first up is breakfast.
I don't know about you,
but I definitely didn't eat
anything this fancy in college.
It was a bagel, maybe toast.
But today, I am making a
ricotta blueberry mug cake.
It's basically like a
fancy pancake in a bowl.
So we have some ricotta,
some maple syrup, butter,
because it makes everything better.
- [Jasmine] Yeah, it does.
- Milk, I'm actually using oat milk today,
because I'm making it for Jasmine,
and I know she loves oat milk.
- [Jasmine] Awww.
- Just gonna whisk that.
So this is a little
challenging trying to whisk
and make sure it's all combined
in this tiny little mug.
This is a no-no in culinary world.
You need to have a bigger
bowl, so you can get in there.
- [Jasmine] I actually
have a hack for this.
- What?
- [Jasmine] I do this
and I just go.
- Oh.
Jasmine is telling me to go
like this and she's right.
(Kelly laughs)
This is perfect, okay.
Now we're gonna add our dry.
We just have some flour,
baking powder, and salt.
Always add salt.
I feel like I say that in every video,
but I love salt and it
makes you feel good.
So this is like an upgraded
fancy pancake for Jasmine,
because I've added ricotta,
which is gonna give it like
a little bit of a tang and
also make it super tender.
Now I'm gonna fold in some
blueberries and that's it.
(spatula banging)
You're definitely gonna wanna cover
all of the meals we're making today,
so it doesn't explode in your microwave
and make a huge mess.
If you're not comfortable with saran wrap,
just put a plate on top,
just cover it, trust me.
(microwave beeping)
All right, so I'm gonna
cook it for three minutes,
check it, and then if it needs more time,
I'll just add one more minute.
(microwave beeping)
So just a heads up, your
cook time will differ
depending on how powerful
your microwave is,
so just keep checking
in to see where it's at.
(microwave beeping)
To make my streusel topping,
I'm gonna add some flour, brown sugar.
Just toss that together.
A little pinch of cinnamon
and then some cubed butter.
Make sure it's cold.
Because I'm really trying
to impress Jasmine,
so I am making a brown sugar crumble.
Everything should be evenly combined
and looks like one cohesive
mass instead of like
bits of flour, bits of butter.
So I'm just gonna put some on top.
I'm gonna cover it one more time.
Put this back in the microwave
for another minute and a half.
All right, let's see
if Chef Mike failed me,
or, oh, oh.
I don't think I should have put
the saran wrap on the second time,
'cause it's like trapping moisture in
and it's just, it's not a crumble.
Chef Mike has failed me,
but I'm gonna put it back in the microwave
and see if I can get those
bits a little crunchier.
All right, I just checked on
it, it's definitely working,
but I'm gonna give it 30 more seconds.
(microwave beeping)
All right.
Honestly, it doesn't look that great,
but I can smell it and I
think it's gonna taste great.
All right, so to garnish this,
I'm just gonna add some fresh blueberries.
I know Jasmine hates warm fruit,
so I'm hoping these cold blueberries
will help balance out
everything and she'll love it.
And to finish, I'm just gonna garnish
with a little powdered sugar.
I'm still not satisfied with the look.
So I went and grabbed a little mint.
It's so cute.
Just adds a pop of color.
All right, let's bring Jasmine in
and see if she gives this
ricotta blueberry cake
a yay or a nay.
All right, you ready to try it?
- [Jasmine] Yes.
- All right, here you go.
- Thank you!
I love.
(hands clapping)
- Yay!
- Whenever I think mug meal,
I think mac and cheese,
lasagna, pizza in a mug.
No one ever thinks of
blueberry ricotta mug cake.
- What do you think of the ricotta?
- So creamy.
- And you get that little bit of tang?
- Mhm.
This is a Jasmine yay.
I know lunch is coming up soon.
- All right, all right,
time to get to work.
Get out of here, let's go!
- All right, I'm taking
this though. (laughs)
- Next up for lunch, I'm making Jasmine
a Thai curry noodle soup.
It is not the most authentic,
but I think it will give you
that curry fix you're looking for it.
We're starting off with
some Thai red curry paste.
Gonna add coconut milk,
water, soy sauce, fish sauce.
And then just like a little pinch of sugar
to balance out all those flavors.
Then I've just julienned
some snow peas just to,
one, add your veggies and give
it a little bit of crunch.
Then I've broken up some
rice noodles in half.
I'm just gonna stick them in there.
Now onto the shrimp.
We are starting with frozen raw shrimp
and this is so it doesn't
over cook in the microwave.
If you're a little worried
about microwaving shrimp,
just make sure that it
is opaque throughout
and not translucent.
I forgot to add my aromatics,
so we are just gonna add a
little bit of ginger powder
and garlic powder.
We know Jasmine loves garlic.
So I'm gonna cover it with a plate
and then pop it in the microwave
for three and a half minutes.
(microwave beeping)
All right.
It smells so good.
That's what's expected.
Look at that!
My shrimp are cooked, the
vegetables stayed green.
That's really surprising.
The noodles look tender.
If you take it out and your noodles
are still a little bit crunchy,
just pop it back in the microwave for like
another minute or two,
'cause you really want them
to be al dente and not raw.
To add a little pizazz,
we're just gonna garnish
it with fresh cilantro.
I can't wait for her to try this.
It smells so good.
Let's see if she likes it.
All right, here's your lunch.
- [Jasmine] Thank you!
- You're welcome.
- Oh my goodness.
You know I love a good nood.
(Kelly laughs)
Dle, dle.
- I didn't know you love a good nood.
- Dle.
(Kelly laughs)
Cheers!
(Jasmine moans)
- Would you ever know
that was from a microwave?
- Mm-mm, never!
Cooked through, al dente,
like it was like perfect.
Big yay from me.
- Two yays so far.
Now I'm gonna make you dinner.
- Thank you so much.
(Kelly laughs)
- I'm so excited about this one.
We're making risotto in the microwave.
We're adding mushrooms,
we're adding thyme.
It's gonna be so delicious.
So we just got some butter and onions.
We are going to saute our onions
for just about 60 seconds in the microwave
to get the cooking process
started and soften them up.
The butter is melted.
They look a little bit softened.
(bowl clanging)
Exactly what we want.
I'm gonna add some garlic,
our mushrooms, some thyme.
You can use fresh or
dried, doesn't matter.
Arborio rice, a little bit of white wine.
Whoa. (laughs)
Got a little excited about the white wine.
Don't worry about the
alcohol, it's gonna cook off,
but you can just leave it
out if you don't want it.
And then a little bit of chicken stock.
You can also use veggie
broth, whatever you like.
All right, so I'm gonna put
this in the microwave covered
for eight minutes
stirring every 90 seconds
just to make sure it doesn't bubble over.
(dishes clanging)
Wow, the rice is fluffy,
it's cooked through.
All right, so the last
step is to just add some
Parmesan and Parmesan is super salty,
so this will really add a
ton of flavor to your dish.
I'm gonna go a little simple
here with the garnish,
just a little bit of cracked black pepper,
'cause I think it really pairs well
with the creaminess of the Parmesan.
And that's it.
Let's go see if she likes it.
All right, dinner time!
- Dinner time!
- I think this is gonna be your favorite.
Looks good.
- Oh my God, I love risotto.
I can't believe you even
made risotto in a microwave.
- I know.
(upbeat music)
(Jasmine moans)
Told you.
- Moment of silence.
(Kelly laughs)
You are unreal.
The mushroom is so rich.
The rice is cooked to perfection.
- Yay or nay?
- Yay!
- Three yays!
- [Jasmine] Yay, baby!
(Kelly laughs)
That is three yays, it's time for dessert.
- Okay!
- Okay?
Last up is dessert.
I know it is Jasmine's
favorite meal of the day,
so I'm making a Snickerdoodle mug cake.
So we're gonna start with some flour,
brown sugar, salt, baking powder.
Just gonna stir this.
Then we're gonna add some water,
melted butter, a little vanilla.
And lastly, a little cinnamon,
because what is Snickerdoodle
without cinnamon?
- [Jasmine] It's just a sugar cookie.
- Just a sugar, that's a sad sugar cookie.
So I'm mixing the batter first in a bowl,
because I'm gonna layer
this batter in my mug
with layers of cinnamon sugar in between.
Is it worth my time?
I don't know, we'll see.
So I'm just gonna pour
a little bit in here.
(mug clanging)
Add a sprinkle of cinnamon sugar.
All right, so more batter,
more sugar, batter.
We'll do a little bit more sugar.
All right, I'm gonna pop
this in the microwave
for a minute and a half.
(microwave beeping)
It smells like cinnamon
sugar heaven in here,
like oh my God.
And just to really make
it special for Jasmine,
I'm gonna add some vanilla ice cream.
All right, we're gonna
add some caramel drizzle
and dark chocolate chips.
Let's get her in and have some dessert.
Dessert!
- Thank you!
(upbeat music)
(Jasmine moans)
This is beautiful.
I just can't believe
everything you made today
is from a microwave.
- So I did well?
- Well?
You did perfect, yay!
- How many Jasmine stars
do you give Chef Mike?
- Four.
- Four, whoo!
- One star for every mug meal.
- You can make gourmet
meals in the microwave.
- You really can.
- Thank you guys for watching.
Let us know in the comments
which one was your favorite.
Bye!
- All of them.
- [Narrator] Oh, yes!
(upbeat music)